[Music]
today for our daily cancellation um i'm
going to be very petty
granted this segment is almost always
petty you know i really could call the
segment five minutes of pettiness and i
would probably capture the spirit of
what i'm doing here but in any case i
i'm feeling especially petty today after
driving into work this morning
and the problem with driving to work
every morning is that i live in
nashville
and though the people of nashville are
wonderful in many ways
they are not wonderful on the road this
town is populated by all of the world's
worst drivers i don't know if bad
drivers come here so they so that they
can be with their own kind maybe
nashville has become something of a
mecca for incompetent motorists they
come here on pilgrimages many die along
the way or maybe after coming here good
drivers become bad
is there something in the water
is there something in the tennessee
whiskey
now i suppose there probably definitely
is something in the whiskey that would
make you a bad driver maybe i've just
solved the riddle i don't know this is a
question for psychiatrists and
anthropologists to study all i know is
that as i drive into nashville
i get a literal front row seat to
witness every bad driving habit every
single morning ramped up by a factor of
10. so just to give you an example the
kind of thing you might encounter as you
travel the highways and byways of our
lovely town
i have on multiple occasions
witness people screech to a halt on the
highway
i mean a dead stop from 70 to zero
so they don't miss their exit i saw a
guy once blow past his exit screech to a
stop
drive onto the shoulder and reverse on
the shoulder back to his exit
i witnessed this because i was the guy
right behind him
the guy who if not for my own incredible
skill i'm the only skilled driver in the
entire state by the way if not for that
i would have rammed right into him
killing him and far more tragically
myself
but he didn't believe that i existed now
for him
the other drivers are mere phantoms
they're aberrations we exist only in the
theoretical he is the only corporeal
life form on the road which is why he
can do whatever he wants and be as
reckless as he wants without fear of
colliding with another solid object
that's how he views it anyway unless
until he learns otherwise and learns it
the hard way and lots of people in
nashville learn that lesson the hard way
every day
i drive about 10 miles to work and in
that 10 miles every day i pass three or
four accidents
every day
and that's if the weather is good if
it's bad or even just mildly unpleasant
the highways look like the walking dead
cars and bodies littered all over the
place a truck flipped upside down
someone's jeep is stuck up in a tree
somehow
a guy in a motorcycle is like dangling
over the overpass
it would appear that as soon as the
first raindrop hits the windshield
people panic and just drive directly
into the nearest object
and this is all very distressing for me
because then i am in the unfortunate
psychological position of feeling
annoyed at all of these people even
though half of them may well be dead
i don't want to be annoyed at your pain
and suffering
i don't i don't like that
but you're making me late for work
and you should have learned to drive
before you got on the
road yes you know yet this is this is
all really i think a preamble to my main
point i could continue complaining about
nashville drivers for another 35 minutes
but i'm not sure how relevant that kind
of content would be to the average
non-national system my main point is
this
i could run all the worst driving habits
on my local roads but none of it is
unique to nashville the volume and
frequency is unique but bad drivers are
everywhere all over this nation of ours
and i have you know i have i have to
navigate around them everywhere i go and
the number one
habit of bad drivers everywhere at least
on the highway
is that they don't know how to merge
i was almost killed yet again this
morning by a bad merger which is why
it's top of my mind and i'll tell you
what happened
i was driving along on the highway
preparing to get off on my exit
see i had already positioned myself in
the right most lane because my exit was
a mile ahead and i wanted to be ready to
take it when the time came i didn't stay
in the left lane until my exit was 25
feet away and then attempt to cut across
four lanes of traffic i didn't do that
you see i was already in the right lane
before the exit comes
but as i was driving in that right lane
anticipating my exit somebody in the
merge lane entering the highway from the
entrance ramp just before my exit
suddenly jerked onto the highway into my
lane going about 15 miles an hour
i had to once again slam on my brakes
saving my life and undeservedly his i
then hit my horn in retribution and
shouted you know you dumbass learned to
drive or whatever but he couldn't hear
me no doubt he went on his merry way
oblivious to the fact that he just had a
near-death experience
for this guy this probably happens every
day his life is saved every day and he
doesn't even know it
now this idiot made the same mistake
that the majority of drivers who are
also idiots
seem to make
somehow you know we require that new
drivers go through a driving test
but merging doesn't make it into the
exam
and the result is that the highway is
filled with suicide bombers and kamikaze
pilots who plunge into traffic taking
their lives into their hands every time
they do it
merging is an art almost entirely lost
in our world today so let me give you
the tutorial
when you're entering the highway you
will notice
that the other cars on the highway
they're all going fast
and this it would seem frightens the
average driver and so they come to a
dead stop in the middle of the merge
lane waiting for a hole in the traffic
not realizing that the hole in traffic
this is physics moves with the traffic
and they then insert themselves into
that gap at a speed about 90 percent
slower than the rest of the cars on the
road
then comes the accident and people die
and worst of all i am inconvenienced
here's the way it's supposed to work
when merging into traffic
you increase your speed
go faster get up to the speed of the
traffic on the road you have a whole
lane remember usually a merge lane will
extend for dozens of feet or more so
make use of that lane that's been given
to you for that purpose speed up pick
your spot seamlessly merge into that
spot while going the same speed as the
cars in front and behind you
if you do it correctly
nobody should have to hit their brakes
at all to accommodate you
if you're waiting for someone to let you
in thinking that you know they'll slam
on their brakes bringing traffic to a
standstill and roll out the red carpet
for you you're not approaching the
situation the right way it is your job
to assimilate yourself into traffic to
become one with the flow of traffic to
take your place on that great dance
floor that is the highway without anyone
else having to break their rhythm
that is your solemn and sacred
responsibility it's why there's a yield
sign in the merge lane not a stop sign
learn the difference
use suicidal maniac
now if all this is too complicated for
you and it is for some people
or if you find highways too intimidating
then stay home
save us all the trouble
save our lives and your own
otherwise i have no choice but to say
you're cancelled well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content